my God  [Music]  are you there God it's me  Margaret  I'm here to speak to you today about  your changing body the blood is released  through the vagina  ceased to this one thing for me  let me just be normal and regular like  everybody else just please please please  please please please please please  please please  [Music]  I've decided I want you to join my  secret Club  if you want to be in the club then you  have to wear a bra  oh  do you you think you need one  are you okay you can tell me the truth  yes we have the campus Improvement  connection  tears social committee fundraising  and how are you  I read that when you don't have any  loved ones around your life expectancy  drops drastically but you know I've had  a good run  foreign  [Music]  trying so hard all the time doesn't it  [Music]  I don't know if I want to do this just  that we're ready please God let it be a  lady  do you think any of us will look like  that when we're 19.  we must we must we must increase  [Music]